おっ
えっ
こんにちははじめ社長です相変わらず筋トレバッグが滑ると南果歩腕がめちゃくちゃ
太くなったんですけどもうやっかっこいいでしょ水で皆さん筋トレしてる方とかもしれ
ない方をしてると思うんですけども
バーベルっていうものをご存知でしょうかここにあるんですけどもうこれも結構重い
ですよね結構多めなんですけども
ああっバーベットや使うんですよこれ黒これどうやって僕使っているかといいますとか
net
女ってこういうベンチプレスんですねそれでよく使ってるんですけども
バーティ基本的超丈夫なんですよねみてくださいこのバベルの幸
こんなにあのう
hey モールはせておれないして曲がらないし結構丈夫に作られているんですけど
もう
もしっかりにもし彼らに僕が金取り出席でものすごい力ついてバーベル行ってこれが
みやげ屋に曲がってしまったら特許に行ってみたいと思いますどうやるかと部が問題な
んですよねこれはバケバケに曲げることができなかったんでトーク
中でをの場合でそっくりの具年前に曲がったニセモノな場合ベル済しましたそれが
こちらでございます手ブロ始めてみると怖いんだよ
すごいすごいすごいすごいポポっすごーっめっちゃそっくりだしめっちゃ軽いしポッっ
めっみてください
キュッ
そうそうですね黒い部分とか調理てますぜっこ
ほぼ一緒じゃない人これもうすごいすごいすごいすごいやすごいはめちゃくちゃ
そっくり午後の部分がめちゃくちゃリアルに再現してもらってます凄い
この便利なカーブですごいところがこれ3 d プリンターで作って
んですよでも細部までめっちゃ曲であるなバーベルそっくりでもうすごいまで作り込み
が結果なく作ったの子供1キロもないけどめちゃくちゃから下を全然感じでお酒れる
ほかテレビ内の体ですごい良いをなんじゃぁなものでもこんなに多さが違うとはうーん
うーん
そういうわけで以上で急いドッキリは普通にまだとリング自分で防御がでトレーニング
してますとこのいつも使ってるねこの1ドット柄くれて来てトレーニングしています
んをっ
トレーニングしてると思ったらあまりによるの力が強すぎてバーメイルがグッディング
でに曲がっちゃった時に行ってみたいと思いますそういう早速筋トレしていきましょう
廃土下座スキッドをやっていきましょうやっぱ胸筋の欲しい酷く結局
でベンツ対するしかない再会石膏積極的にやってますけど
焼いて肩が痛くなるんです
こんな感じでやっている
あげてきの
tan
メモを使うべきで受け取る町胸筋の端ねうではー
使わない感じです
はいこんな感じで運営を伝えているわけでございます
話がそれました
[音楽]
a
東レちゃダメでしょそれ a 立派
no なぜのつずつ今とれちゃいけないが撮れませんけど大丈夫俺なんか
[音楽]
あああいうえすだけています私は来る日も来る日もトレーニングを続けた結果
パーれるがグニャグニャになったんだなぁ
どうぞ
[音楽]
[拍手]
いやー
[音楽]
八橋ん
なにそれ
何それ何それやばいって何で
なにこれ言えませんじゃー
すぎてください見て
難しいんですよやる側抜き
やられるがいろんなパターンやってみましょうか
次はここに多いときだけで行くやってみます
いや総合とヤバイですこれいつも真っ直ぐな効果こうなっている彦強いと思うんで
やっています
[音楽]
hey hey
沿って南へ
yeah
大江
踊った
ポコノ井
捕食者うん
用例こっちのほうがいいですね
が俺でやってると不自然だからな
[音楽]
動作
ふぅ
んえっ
そう
g やーん
すごー
[音楽]
ブーバーしまーっ
腹ええええええっ
[音楽]
あ
ん
じゃあやばいめっちゃ曲がった
いい
いよう別ですねっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
言わん
っていうのでございました
[音楽]
なければいつもボロい
4 a
[音楽]
やばいよね受けませです
思います
ちょっとねええええええ
いいいいいいいいいい
ん
フォーツースをやるぞ
わー
んがぁああああ
ああああああん
[音楽]
なぜ速いし
じゃん
なんです
仰っても何ヶ月か打っていたね
あああああなにこれ
これ大丈夫てこないでしょどうぞ
[音楽]
姉あのって
自分で自分を維持あこれくれよ
me
あああああ
ああああああああ
ブーブーブーブー
ああああああ
さーああああ
んですわぁ
me
本当にで a
ああああああ
ん